I'm gonna tell you story at first it's
gonna sound ridiculous but the longer I
talk we have to find the keys the more
rational it's going to appear I can't
believe you found coffee right yeah
three how many times have we been here
how many times for me it's been an
eternity
the invasion will fail we lose
everything
I died within five minutes of landing on
that beach along with every other
soldier
how did you do that come on come find me
when you wake up
you do know what's happening to me what
happened to you happen to me you
hijacked that power how do I control you
have to die every day keep coming here
and I'll train you again
your legs broken no I'm good any better
start over
I'm not a soldier of course you know
your listen
they want to conquer the rest of the
world
unless you change them you're not
equipped for what something
how many times are we penny what are you
not telling me
that's gonna be dark in a few hours I'm
curl up by the fire and open a bottle of
wine we should just reset whoa